on décrypte maintenant la situation en
afghanistan avec nos invités elle
faillit mais robiolle chargé de cours à
l'essai qui osent université dotée en
mai kaboul et vice présidente du club
france afghanistan et myriam et belrad
politologue français spécialiste du
monde arabe
bonsoir à toutes les deux le merci
d'être avec nous ce soir sur rtl france
alors on l'a dit les talibans sont
entrés ce matin dans kaboul et vont
prendre le pouvoir un d'ici les
prochaines heures est ce que le retour
des talibans on sait la défaite de
l'occident et particulièrement des
etats-unis a failli mer au viol et
bonjour et merci de m'avoir invité et
moi je pense que ce qu'on peut observer
et c'est la réalisation accélérée et de
plants de maïs à lizac qui était envoyé
spécial des etats-unis et qui a fait un
plan
proposition de paix et qui emmenait dans
sa proposition est arrivée d'un
gouvernement de transition
la participation des talibans 50 50 ans
parlement dans lequel bar allemand
existant dans lequel il allait avoir
également les talibans une conseil est
suprême
pour que ce qu'on sait suprême est
rédigée par et les clergés est taliban
qui a approuvé un ensemble d décret loi
et puis les articles de la constitution
et et puis l'arrivée des talibans donc
petit à petit qu'on envoie ces
acheminements de ce projet là ce projet
rapidement a été mise en oeuvre
elle par le fait est que les
négociations des talibans avec les états
unis sans que la population et les
afghans soient intégrés à démoraliser
complètement
le peuple et les et l'état afghan au
contraire a donné beaucoup d'énergie aux
talibans et puis est quelque chose qui
voulait il ya un partage de pouvoir à 50
50 ils ont commencé leur offensive de
printemps et puis on a demandé ce qu'on
a demandé dollars mais de faire un
retrait tactique
a fait est que il n'y a pas eu de
résistance et qu'
ils ont gagné non pas seulement 50% d
aider des régions pour venir à la table
de négociation encore plus forte parce
que l'état afghan n'était pas d'accord
bien partage 50/50 et on arrive
maintenant à cette situation là où ils
sont à carouge la millième benraad le
président afghan a sera organisée à
quitter le pays dans l'après midi et a
déclaré tout à l'heure que les talibans
avaient gagné comment analyser justement
cette cette attitude est cette sortie du
président afghan
est-ce que vous l'entendez bien parce
que quand tu vois année par le traité
alors je vous avoue qu'on ne vous entend
pas très très bien mais allez-y et puis
on essaiera peut s'adapter en fonction
non mais
au
rayon
c'est très intéressant autre question
les
etats-unis ont
la rage
est à peu près dans tous les cas
vous entends très très mal on va on va
essayer avec nos équipes de deux d'avoir
une meilleure liaison avec vous et on va
revenir vous voir dans quelques instants
faille mais robiolle je vous pose la
même question qu'à la came here i am
abend rade à l'instant comment justement
interprété cette attitude du président
ashraf ghani et qui a quitté
l'afghanistan en début d'après-midi et
puis qui a déclaré il ya quelques
instants que les talibans avaient gagné
et écouter la veille il a déclaré qu'il
va combattre jusqu'au bout 7 7
combat pour protéger
le peuple afghan moi je pense qu'il ya
avec l'arrivée de 3000
forces armées des états unis augmentent
et maintenant à 5000 je pense que il
n'avait pas d'autre choix de bouquets de
partir la population on l'a vu dans
notre reportage tout à l'heure la partie
en tout cas de la population pourraient
bien ne réagirais bien accueillir le
retour des talibans à kaboul en
afghanistan est ce que c'est quelque
chose qui me surprend
alors ce que je peux vous dire depuis
quelques semaines que ils ont gagné plus
en plus les et les régions
ils ont commis beaucoup beaucoup de
violence ils ont obligé les filles de 12
ans de fait peu plus par force d'eau et
épouser les talibans et certains ont
embarqué les ces jeunes femmes la force
et de mariage avec avec eux les magasins
brûler les maisons brûlées et elle et
les historiens les cinéastes
enfin notez tout ce qui est des
comédiens ont été ont été tués
par une violence inouïe et de plus
depuis hier quand ils sont arrivés au
camp d'art et à
allonnes indépendamment de cette
violence là on a observé qu'ils ont pas
qu'ils ont empêché les professeurs
femmes et d'aller à l'université ainsi
que les filles en dix ans professeur
femme que vous allez être remplacé
parler par les hommes donc quand on voit
cette côté de la vérité et le fait qu'il
y a des milliers de personnes qui depuis
plusieurs jours essaye de fuir les
talibans est entré à kaboul dans une
situation catastrophique ou très
alarmant en ce qui concerne l'hygiène
les bébés à 35 degrés et qui buzze
outils ont besoin du lait de l'eau et
puis la situation associée à cornes un
virus et pour moi
qui entend depuis pas mal de temps les
propagande des talibans
lors déclarations
je les met sous toute réserve alors on a
retrouvé la liaison avec mme mirian
bentrad
vous avez entendu tout de suite les les
exactions commises par les talibans dans
leur retour au pouvoir
la famille royale parlait des femmes
quel rôle pour les pour les femmes si
les talibans reviennent au pouvoir
d'abord j'aimerais reprendre si vous le
permettez mon début de réponse et je
vais vous répondre dans la foulée sur
les femmes parce que c'est un lien là il
sur les stratégies américaines bonjour
la stratégie américaine consistait tout
de même il faut le rappeler à éliminer
al-qaïda alors quand on voit aujourd'hui
à situation 2021 en afghanistan avec ce
déferlement déferlante talibane les
choses c'est vraiment un échec total le
djihadisme international n'a jamais été
aussi puissant qu'aujourd'hui en tout
cas en afghanistan il reprend la main
par ailleurs les talibans ont libéré un
certain nombre de prisonniers jihadistes
on voit bien qu'ils ne sont pas du tout
dans une logique de transition pacifique
et d'ailleurs toutes les déclarations
qui sont faites
excusez moi mais sont à prendre
pour ce qu'elles sont c'est à dire un
tissu de mensonges sur de nombreux
points il avait déclaré en février 2020
vouloir partager le enfin être prêt à
des négociations avec le gouvernement
afghan vouloir et être dans une logique
de partage du pouvoir or ils se sont
emparés par la force militaire de
l'ensemble du pays jusqu'à des salles à
kaboul où ils ont ils ont mis en suspens
si vous voulez l'idée d'une
confrontation armée pour la simple et
bonne raison que les forces armées
afghanes ce sont des bandes et que les
officiels et généreront piqué le pays
qu'il n'a plus aujourd'hui de
gouvernement afghan sauf une peau de
chagrin et la question des femmes
allaient très intéressante parce que les
grandes victimes de cette guerre civile
afghane qui dure en fait depuis trente
ans et des de l'occupation américaine de
l'occupation occidentale et ses
lendemains c'est à dire l'art le retour
des talibans les grandes vitesses où
sont les femmes et je précise d'ailleurs
que les femmes n'ont pas été victimes
seulement des talibans en grande part
des talibans mais aussi des forces
afghanes et des forces étrangères qui
n'ont eu aucune espèce de de
préoccupation pour le sort des femmes et
aujourd'hui on le voit la communauté
internationale par c'est évacuer ses
ressortissants
déconseille tout voyage en afghanistan
donc a complètement abandonné les femmes
à leurs stores et ça va être un drame
total vous parliez à l'instant à mian
benraad vais rester avec vous on vous a
pas trop entendu ce soir vous parliez
justement de la communauté
internationale quel va être son rôle
dans l'est dans les semaines dans l'est
dans les mois à venir est ce que des
négociations sont sont possibles avec
les talibans
mais pour l'instant la communauté
internationale allait bien embêté
notamment les occidentaux parce qu'il
n'ya plus il n'y aura plus d'ici
quelques jours avec les évêques évêques
d'évacuation des missions diplomatiques
et de tous les ressortissants étrangers
à commencer par les ressortissants
occidentaux
il n'y aura plus aucune représentation
politique
occidentale en afghanistan
donc comment dans ces conditions les
gossip quoi que ce soit avec les
talibans les talibans ont rassuré
effectivement par ses déclarations
disant ne vous fera rien il n'y aura
mais qu'est-ce qu'on peut négocier avec
un pouvoir fondamentalistes qui libère
les djihadistes ces mêmes djihadistes
qui frappe en occident et partout
ailleurs et je j'aimerais rajouter une
chose quand même après je reste la
parole à mon interlocutrice mais il y a
quand même des questions à se poser sur
la rapidité de cette offensive pourquoi
les états unis romati les clés de
l'afghanistan aussi vite aux talibans il
n'y a t'il pas une volonté de
déstabilisation régionale on peut se
poser la question quand même parce que
les états unis ont vraiment excusez-moi
jeter le bébé avec l'eau du bain en
images ça c est l affaire d'un an un an
et demi on peut se poser des questions
sur les véritables motivations de ce
retrait entre précipitée alors je veux
bien sûr les américains ont échoué mais
pourquoi partir aussi brutalement en
risquant une
une déstabilisation régionale d'ensemble
et quel état les etats-unis
souhaiteraient qu'il déstabilise et je
pense bien évidemment à l'iran et à la
russie et à songer à son voisinage fahim
et robien l'on revient ensemble sur ce
qui est dit à l'instant bien manade sur
la négociation avec avec les talibans
est ce que c'est c'est une analyse que
vous partagez
il est compliqué les voir même
impossible de négocier avec des
fondamentalistes
déjà l'expérience de doha nous a montré
qu'à partir de moins à une carte de
négociation vous avez une partie qui ne
vient pas une partie qui fait semblant
d'être présents ou bien apprendre donc
on les attend ils font de voyages de
tourisme et au mot on arrivait saoudite
en iran au pakistan en chine en russie
et on les reçoit comme anelka or très
peu de temps avant il était considéré
est un groupe terroriste qu'on accepte
et toutes leurs revendications y compris
quand vient d'être dit armada libération
de cinq mille prisonniers qu'elle a dit
qu'ils ont tout de suite pris la main et
qu'après ils ont demandé encore 7000
autres et c'était une négociation avec
une partie et qui se sentait très très
fort qu'ils n'avaient aucune attention
et que les autres ont les presser et les
presser pour donner des points par
construction cette négociation ne
pouvait pas
tenir la route quant aux américains et
on dit souvent et qui mais il pouvait
pas rester plus qu'au bâton mais ils
pouvaient très bien savoir il ya dix ans
qu'est ce qu'ils ont entrepris ne
marchait pas merci merci fait mais en vf
désolé vous vous coupez aussi aussi
brusquement malheureusement on manque de
temps mais merci en tout cas faille mais
rabiole d'avoir été avec nous je
rappelle que vous êtes chargé de cours à
l'essec et aux universités de téhéran et
kaboul et vice présidente du club france
afghanistan et merci également à vous et
meriem abed rabbo d'avoir été avec nous
vous êtes sa politologue français
spécialisé dans le monde arabe merci
beaucoup